merci beaucoup bonjour bonjour est notre
invité politique ce matin c'est gilles
platret merci beaucoup merci à vous une
idée notre invitation maire de chalon
sur saône vice présidents des
républiques en détention pendant 20
minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse quotidienne
régionale représentée par stéphane bern
et de ouest france bonjour stéphane
bonjour bonjour et on va commencer
évidemment par cette nomination est
fière de l'esab est borgne à matignon
qui succède donc à jean castex et les
événements de premières minutes c'est un
bon choix pour vous coûter en tout cas
c'est pas le choix de la surprise ou de
l'effet waouh c'est un personnage avec
un parcours et mines ont très
respectable et je veux pas faire de
procès d'intention mais c'est vrai que
le suspense qui avait ménagé le
président de république laissé entendre
que il souhaiterait peut-être par un
effet de surprise reprendre la main ça
n'est pas le cas on est dans une
continuité totale avec le précédent
gouvernement dont madame borne est issu
et puis les locales que je suis note
quand même que maintenant à la tête de
l'état on a deux parcours là aussi
éminent celui d' emmanuel macron celui
de madame la première ministre qui sont
des parcours qui ont complètement
oublié l'échelon local la dure réalité
du terrain c'était pas le cas et
pourtant les a combattus avec edouard
philippe ou jean castex qui avait cette
fibre du terrain là c'est un autre choix
qui est fait je suis pas sûr que ça soit
de bonne augure pour les collectivités
et les citoyens on le verra encore une
fois on attendra le discours de
politique générale c'est ce qu'il va
vraiment marqué les esprits mais en tout
cas l'a priori et pas emballé voilà je
vais le dire comme ça on s'attendait à
quelque chose d'un peu plus d'un peu
plus surprenant comment vous expliquer
qu'il ait fallu trois semaines pour
nommer cette nouvelle première ministre
alors que son nom circulait avant même
l'élection prévue et vous avez raison
bon d'abord le président et mettre son
agenda ça énerve beaucoup mais après
tout c'est lui qui décide du tempo il a
souhaité aller au terme de son mandat
pour pouvoir nommer ensuite
le remplaçant ou la remplaçante de jean
castex donc je trouve pas que ce soit à
normale même si c'est toujours un peu
pénible d'attendre mais vous avez vu ça
nous a permis de faire une revue de à
peu près la moitié de l'échiquier
politique français on a pu apprendre des
tas de biographies d' audrey azoulay et
de tant d'autres dont les noms étaient
cités arnaud montebourg et c est
finalement bon voilà on arrive qu'on
citait y avait des gens droite j'ai le
plâtre est bien sûr très nouveau train
bien sûr bien sûr d'accord pour
regretter que ça ne soit pas une
première ans de droite ça mais enfin je
pense que je ne regretterai jamais que
home évite un peu plus de confusion
politique vous savez que le maquereau
nisme c'est d'abord la confusion des
idées il n'est sur le mélange droite
gauche c'est pas leurs dépassements
c'est l'utilisation de la droite et de
la gauche pour durer dans le temps donc
c'est l'absence d'idéologie donc des
personnalités de droite ne se retrouve
pas en nombre au gouvernement où croyez
moi ça va pas me faire pleurer je pense
bah écoutez en tout cas ça serait plus
clair ça serait plus clair
regardez regardez ce qui s'est passé
avec les deux premiers ministres qui
viennent d'officiers sous l'égide des
manuels macron ce sont des hommes qui
sont venus notre famille politique les
républicains qui l'ont évidemment
quitter en rejoignant le maquereau nisme
et qui ont cautionné voir organisé par
la politique gouvernementale à laquelle
ils ont présidé une politique qui à nos
yeux n'est pas de droite en matière
régaliennes la droite n'a pas l'apanage
du bon sens mais il nous semble que l'
immigration débridée n'est pas le signe
d'une politique de droite que la
faiblesse on y reviendra sans doute de
la lutte conte en lice contre
l'islamisme n'est pas non plus un
marqueur qui signerait un gouvernement
de droite donc je pense aujourd'hui que
sur les sujets régaliens monsieur macron
a montré qu'il n'allait pas de ce côté
là de l'échiquier en revanche salon son
habileté à se servir du marqueur de
droite pour essayer de faire croire
qu'il est sur tous les tableaux la
confusion elle existe aussi chez les
républicains hier vous aviez christian
jacob qui critiquaient le la domination
de de d'elisabeth mort nés pendant sa
bagagerie pécresse l'a félicité écoutez
c'est peut-être une autre approche
simplement de prise en compte de prise
de fonction en disant voilà les
réactions je suis pas sûr que si vous
voulez parler des différences et
républicain on peut en faire des livres
là je vais pas je peux pas vous dire
qu'il n'a pas de juniors déjà mais je
pense que c'est pas là-dessus qu'elles
vont se mesurer sur la réaction à la
nomination c'est surtout sur les axes
politiques là aussi on y reviendra sans
doute cette famille politique elle même
et en travail est hilare a besoin de se
clarifier dans l'avenir ça se jouera je
pense sur des sujets encore plus
fondamentaux que la réaction à une
domination qu'est ce que vous dites
qu'ils sont encore au gouvernement est
ce que vous le savez un message à leur
faire passer avec cette nouvelle
première ministre non je n'ai pas de
message je pense que
ils n'ont pas de message de recevoir ils
ont plutôt un bilan à présenter au pays
moi je n'ai pas satisfaits et c'est pas
parce qu'ils sont de chez nous on
pourrait aussi avoir des critiques
vis-à-vis de personnages politiques y
sont venues d'ailleurs leur bilan n'est
pas bon quand je vois monsieur darmanin
qui roule des mécaniques pour interdire
le burqini à grenoble alors que dans
cette noble maison du sénat il s'est
opposé il ya quelques mois un amendement
du sénateur savin qui voulait interdire
le bikini burqini je me dis qu'on est
dans quelque chose qui n'est pas honnête
quand je vois monsieur le maire qui a
trois semaines nous disait la france va
mieux qu'ailleurs la france est sorties
d'affaires et qui tout d'un coup la
semaine dernière a pris conscience que
nous avions un mur devant nous et que
nous y accélérons c'est à dire le mur de
la dette le mur du déficit extérieur le
mur de l'inflation et tout ça ça signe
des échecs donc j'ai pas de leçons alors
donné ils ont fait leur choix encore une
fois ils n'appartiennent plus depuis
longtemps maintenant à notre famille
politique tout cas plus de regrets à
avoir vis-à-vis d'eux par contre ils ont
des bilans et dont ils en sont
comptables donc il faudrait je pense en
tout cas un peu d'humidité de leur part
mais nous serons là aussi on verra bien
s'ils sont de nouveau gouvernement mais
nous serons là aussi pour rappeler que
leur bilan n'est pas bon il ya des
membres des républicains pour vous qui
sont susceptibles de rentrer dans ce
nouveau man qui va être un mais je
serais tenter de vous dire que je ne le
souhaite pas mais je sais bien que des
approches ont été faites vous en avez
rendu compte comme d'autres maintenant
on va attendre quand même le dernier
moment moi j'ai toujours souhaité qu et
de la clarté vous savez on est dans une
démocratie on a le droit d'avoir des
idées différentes les uns les autres
d'ailleurs sans ça il n'y a pas de débat
mais on a un devoir c'est d'arrêter d'en
changer toutes les 5 minutes en fonction
des opportunités politiques on peut
vivre une vie extraordinaire sans
devenir ministre et je le dis à certains
des miens qui sont souvent tentés de
faire des contorsions gymnique pour
arriver à se contredire et à être en
cours est rentré incident gouvernement
ça n'apporte rien ok ça leur fera une
ligne sur leur fiche wikipédia mais ça
n'apporte rien au débat politique est au
contraire quand on a un ralliement de ce
genre faut voir les effets désastreux
que ça produit chez nos compatriotes
faut pas croire que la prise de guerre
vous savez la fameuse prise de guerre
j'ai pris un tel à telle partie pour
essayer de le détruire mais la prise de
guerre elle est terrible dans l'opinion
publique elle donne l'image d'une
absence totale de conviction et d'une
démocratie qui est en train de se
déliter donc c'est une mauvaise chose
alors après je sais que la tentation est
grande en tout cas j'espère que certains
qui sont aujourd'hui nommé pour
peut-être rentrer un gouvernement ni
céderons pas parce que ils vont jouir
d'une gloire éphémère mais ils ont
surtout porté une eau propre qui durera
longtemps c'est un message entre autres
sites mais je les demande est très tôt
je souhaitais un peu isolé d'ailleurs
dans ma famille politique vous savez
j'étais présent au conseil stratégique
lorsque nous avons voté une ligne
c'était une semaine après les élections
c'était même le lendemain d'élections
présidentielles du deuxième tour une
ligne et henning me semble t'il la très
claire nous restons dans l'indépendance
de nos idées nous ne nous rallions pas à
la majorité présidentielle
il ya eu deux personnages par ailleurs
éminent encore une fois c'est pas une
attaque personnelle c'est damien abad et
philippe juvin qui ont refusé de voter
settings et les seuls où tout le monde a
accepté l'idée de dire qu'il fallait que
nous restions indépendant sinon nous
allions disparaître complètement eh bien
je pense qu'à ce titre là le président
du groupe des députés ne suivant pas et
ni d'indépendance ne peut pas rester
président du groupe de députés
thione dès maintenant je vais dit déjà
mais je n'ai je ne suis je suis un peu
isolé dans ma famille politique
qu'est-ce qu'on attend qu'ils rentrent
au gouvernement pour finalement que les
gros titres soit le président des
députés aient l'air rejoint monsieur
macrohori des missionnaires j'ai créé
st-jacques de bâle exclure tant qu'il
n'a pas franchi le pas il n'a pas besoin
d'autres exclus mais après il ya aussi
une question de logique politique et
d'honnêteté intellectuelle
damien abad et quelqu'un d'honnête sais
pas ce que je veux dire je ne parle pas
d'une honnêteté qui dépasserait le côté
de l'engagement mais s'il veut être
honnête avec les idées qu'il a défendu
avec les électeurs et les militants qui
l'ont aidé à être là où il est il doit
démissionner de la présidence du groupe
des républicains immédiatement pour lui
bien sûr s'arrête déjà dû être fait pour
donner un blindé fils julien vous avez
été très clair est-ce que vous allez
vous avez d'autres personnes sur votre
liste alors ces contorsions gemini qui
vous dit entre autres non mais en maison
il bouclé mais non mais vous vous les
connaissez il ya un certain nombre de
parlementaires mais je vais pas me
lancer je vais pas être comme
robespierre promettant une liste parce
que vous avez vu comment ça finit en
plus il a tardé à la présenter et ça lui
a coûté la vie non je pense simplement
que vous connaissez les profils comme
moi il ya un certain nombre de personnes
qui sont tentés de rejoindre le
maquereau nisme et bien à la rigueur
qu'il le fasse mais qu'il ne reste pas
dans l'antre de nous ce que nous
demandons c'est simplement la clarté on
peut pas être à la fois aux républicains
et chez monsieur macron on a vraiment
posé le principe de l'interdiction
complète de la double appartenance et je
pense que ça principes sains en tout cas
c'est un principe respectueux des
lecteurs on peut pas tromper les gens en
se faisant élire avec le soutien d'une
formation politique et en travaillons
avec l'adversaire de cette formation
politique et ça c'est pas possible est
ce que vous allez faire pour damien abad
est ce que vous maintenez à ce qu'ils
font et maintenir l'investiture des
républicains écoutez moi je l'aurais
était de semer on a encore quelques
jours peut-être pour régler la question
qui pense qu'à partir du moment où en
marche par l'intermédiaire de son
président monsieur guérini a annoncé que
monsieur à bâle n'aurait pas
d'adversaires face à lui dans sa
circonscription c'est une investiture
qui ne dit pas son nom évidemment il n'a
pas été officiellement investi par la
majorité présentielle mais il n'a pas
d'adversaire de la majorité présentielle
ce qui revient à rigoureusement même je
pense que notre famille s'honorerait à
avoir un candidat contre lui qui porte
nos couleurs encore une fois c'est une
logique politique je le dis vraiment
nous avons besoin d'art amener de la
clarté la droite républicaine se
refondre assure la clarté ou alors elle
disparaîtra si nous continuons de
cultiver l'ambiguïté si nous continuons
de tolérer l'ambiguïté alors nous
finirons vraiment par disney ont voulu
retirer il si vous
retient l'investiture vous présenter un
candidat à l'air face à lui en tout cas
c'est ce que moi j'aurais souhaité
effectivement mais on verra bien c'est
proposé à christian jacob on a eu des
discussions à un moment donné les uns
les autres j'ai pas à en rendre compte
ici mais en tout cas je pense que c'est
mais on le dépôt limite vous savez c'est
vendredi et donc on verra si d'ici
vendredi les choses se passent comme je
le souhaite et comme nous sommes
également un certain nombre à le
souhaiter mais c'est quoi la ligne rouge
c'est la fin qui rentre au gouvernement
c'est le fait que déjà il n'est pas
d'adversaire en marche et que donc il ya
un accord y attendait oui mais bien sûr
c'est pour ça qu'ils seraient des grand
temps d'agir la clarté que vous évoquez
est ce qu'elle ne risque pas de vous
coûter très cher aux prochaines
législatives mais qu'est ce fait de
s'allier en alliage attelage avec lui
dit mais le risque c'est de l'ailé
centriste hervé morin d'ailleurs c'est
de se retrouver c'est de cette paire
d'un très grand nombre de sièges à
l'assemblée
c'est pas grave ça sur ses idées
justes en service en non mais je veux
juste insister là dessus parce que votre
question elle est fondamentale est ce
que il faut accepter le prix d'une
survie dans la dissolution au sein d'une
majorité présidentielle ma réponse est
non il faut défendre ses idées les
électeurs sont souverains les idées ne
meurt pas elles peuvent avoir des aléas
dans les élections nous pouvons nous
retrouver et très peu de députés la
prochaine fois mais les idées demeurent
nos convictions demeurent les combats
que nous avons porté pour les défendre
dans le passé cela on ne les efface pas
et je ne souhaite pas qu'on les méprise
et qu'on méprise ceux qui les ont menés
avec nous en changeant d'étiquettes
c'est ça en fait la réalité aujourd'hui
et je pense que très honnêtement il vaut
mieux se lancer au risque de perdre dans
la fidélité à ses convictions que de se
rallier à des conditions qui n'ont
jamais
résonnera mais il ya quand même il ya
quand même un risque à l'arrivée et bien
sûr qu'hier sur le financement oui oui
un échec de plus après en avoir cumulé
un certain nombre ça peut faire aussi
très vous avez raison vous avez raison
mais on ne rebâtit ras rien dans
l'ambiguïté parce qu'il faut penser à la
législative qui s'avance faut surtout
penser à la reconstruction d'une famille
politique et nous avons cinq ans pour le
faire c'est à dire dans quelles
conditions nous présenterons nous aux
élections présidentielles dans cinq ans
c'est ça l'effet ans majeur ici et si on
ne fait pas cette épreuve de clarté et
bien on ne se présentera pas dans de
bonnes conditions mentales et de la
reconstruction pour finir sur la clarté
puisque vous nous dit stanislas guérini
a dit je ne présente pas de candidat
face à damien abad pour moi ça et qui
voit un accord est ce que vous dit la
même chose faire exulter eric zemmour a
dit moi je présente pas de candidat face
à eric ciotti est ce que là aussi ça et
qu'il vend un accord non alors là je
peux vous dire il n'y a pas eu d'accord
entre eric ciotti et monsieur zemmour
monsieur zemmour vous savez moi je la
différence je vais vous dire une chose
c'est que reconquête en ce moment pour
l'opération survie de reconquête c'est
de faire croire que l ménages incertain
en moi j'ai eu droit alors il se trouve
que voilà sur le territoire qui est le
mien il y aura des candidats toutes les
couleurs donc il n'y a pas d'ambiguïté
là dessus en revanche on voit bien que
reconquête essaie de faire croire que
finalement peuvent travailler avec nous
que c'est toujours la thématique de
l'union des droites et cette façon de ne
pas mettre de candidat face à eric
ciotti c'est une façon d'y aimé regarder
nous faisons l'union des drags c'est pas
un message pour la circonscription
d'eric ciotti pardonnez moi je pense
qu'eric ciotti qui va être réélu n'a pas
besoin de ne pas avoir d'adversaire de
reconquête pour être réélu il n'y a pas
d'accord n'est pas clarifiée eric ciotti
mais il a besoin de clarifier mes
victoires et qui l'a pas fait d'accord
la paf est d'accord attendez vous à
berlin non mais attendez vous avez d'un
côté damien abad je peux faire une
fixation mais qui vous l'avez vous
l'avez su comme moi à rencontrer
monsieur solaire en particulier à
l'elysée a discuté avec lui de quoi de
la pluie du beau temps ou d'un accord
politique et de l'autre eric ciotti qui
mène sa campagne d'une manière
indépendante on peut par contre quand
même mettre les deux sur le même plan
fin à tant d eric ciotti a toujours été
fidèle à ses convictions il en a et
jamais dévié il n'est pas en train de se
rallier à reconquête le doute est en
revanche permis du côté du député de
l'ain dont on a largement parlé ce matin
est ce que vous avez été tenté un moment
de quitter les républicains et de
rejoindre la partie rencontre j'ai été
approché et je mentirais en disant que
le discours d'eric zemmour m'a toujours
laissé insensible c'est très clair je
n'ai pas un mot d'ailleurs j'ai souvent
pris la parole sur ce sujet en revanche
je suis resté dans ma famille politique
pour plusieurs raisons d'abord y avait
des fidélités
au combat qu'on a mené à christian jacob
voilà qui je redis encore mon amitié
parce qu'il a fait un travail
extraordinaire et complètement
désintéressé ce qui est absolument
rarissime à ce niveau de responsabilité
à la tête des républicains et puis il y
avait aussi je pense en tout cas c'est
comme ça que je l'analyse est une dérive
de reconquête vers un passage finalement
du conservatisme qui pouvait d'ailleurs
nous convenir un certain nombre à une
espèce de deux mélanges réactionnaires
qui s'est affirmé au fil de la campagne
et qui finit par exemple la dernière
image de campagne
monsieur zemmour il est avec monsieur de
villiers ou qui d'un hôtel de sainte
clotilde alors moi je n'ai pas de
problème avec la religion chrétienne
mais je pense qu'à un moment donné il
faut mettre des bornes et on peut pas
fonder une campagne uniquement sur de la
réaction donc il ya un moment donné des
principes républicains qui doit être
réaffirmée par tous vis-à-vis de tous et
moi j'ai senti cette dérive ça veut pas
dire que le constat qu eric zemmour a
fait de la société française des menaces
qui pèsent sur elle parce que là pour le
coup je mens partager une grande partie
ce constat vaut toujours et d'ailleurs
il est le seul à avoir apporté un peu de
nouveauté dans cette campagne
présidentielle qui était écrite par
avance ne l'oublions jamais donc tout
n'est pas à jeter je ne dis pas ça avec
mépris je dis simplement que je pense
que le chemin qui était pris dans la
campagne n'a pas été un bon chemin et
puis je vais le dire aussi clairement il
était une erreur d'accueillir marion
maréchal-le pen il était une erreur de
soutenir marine le pen cette famille est
un clan qui sera toujours solidaire au
final et qui tacle ans qui n'est pas
prêt heureusement d'ailleurs à gouverner
la france donc je pense quoi là pour
tout ces 13 où ces raisons là et
d'autres encore mais en tout cas elle
soit si les principales je n'ai pas
rejoint je ne regrette pas aujourd'hui
est l'une des raisons c'est votre
fidélité à christian jacob
qui va quitter la tête du parti après
les législatives et l'annoncé vous êtes
candidat à sa succession on verra bien
il ya beaucoup de vous savez chaque jour
il y en a de plus donc je veux pas
rajouter de la confusion non je suis
président du paris mais bien sûr mais à
la rigueur ça pour être légitime mais
d'abord étape alors j'ai envie peut-être
pas de la présidence des républicains on
verra bien mais j'ai surtout envie de
participer très clairement à la
refondation de nos idées je pense que
notre parti en inde et à l'air ou en
dehors des as l'air j'espère que ça
pourra être au sein mais vous en doutez
je me pose aujourd'hui des questions sur
l'état dans lequel nous aurons passé
cette épreuve colossal pour nous de 2022
s'il n'y a pas une clarification
idéologique s'il n'y a pas un moment
donné
le parti pris de dire voici quelles sont
nos valeurs et voici ces valeurs que
nous défendons et à partir de là de
rassembler autour de ses valeurs et non
pas de rassembler des gens qui n'ont pas
les mêmes valeurs dans une même écurie
j'espère que je me fais bien compris
particulièrement il peut plus aller
d'eric ciotti à xavier bertrand ces sacs
d'une musique oui bien sûr je pense
qu'il ya aujourd'hui des grands écarts
qui sont pas tenables et d'ailleurs on
en a payé le prix à la présidentielle et
alors il doit les verts ont plutôt vers
ma fidélité politique c'est celle des
valeurs d'une droite qui s'affirme voilà
donc je serais si vous me demandez de
choisir entre les deux bien sûr je vais
vous dire eric ciotti mais c'est pas
eric ciotti qui est en cours mais c'est
la colère ne doivent plus être un parti
de la droite et du centre pour vous ça
va être un parti de droite ils doivent
travailler avec le centre moi je vais
vous dire j'ai fait cette alliance pour
les régionales l'année dernière on a été
en capacité de travailler droite et
sandres ensemble mais dans le respect de
chacun moi j'ai pas de problème à faire
une alliance avec lui des i avec les
centristes mais à condition que nous
soyons nous mêmes c'est à dire un parti
de droite et quand vous est écartelé
dans votre sein lorsque vous prenez des
positions et que immédiatement vous avez
un garde chiourme qui vous dit au sein
même de votre famille politique c'est
pas bien c'est pas mort à le dire ça ça
peut pas tenir c'est une confusion que
les électeurs ont sanctionné et donc on
a besoin de cette clarification
moi je crois que nos idées ont encore de
l'importance je ne dirais pas comme
certain qu'elles sont majoritaires dans
le pays parce que c est majoritaire on
aurait gagné l'élection mais en tout cas
elle existe et notre fierté ça sera des
défenses de la clarification et la
reconstruction des airs elle passe aussi
par législatives et législatives est-ce
que vous même vous serez candidat et
pourquoi est-ce qu'on n'avait pas encore
pris votre décision alors je fais comme
monsieur macron je suis maître d'un
calendrier j'y tiens
bien sûr et oui c'est pour ça que j'ai
fait les louanges du chef de l'état en
disant qu'il avait raison de prendre son
temps le contexte local
qu'on va pas détailler ici m'amène à
prendre une décision au dernier moment
donc nous sommes mardi le dépôt limite
des candidatures c'est à vendre à jour
je vous assure que d'ici là la décision
sera prise
je vous dirai en temps et heure et je le
dirai publiquement quelle sera ma
décision un à un mot sur le burqini
puisqu'on en a partout d'ailleurs mais
c'est quand même important le projet
municipal de grenoble a autorisé le port
du burkini dans les piscines vous êtes
opposé cette vision qu'a ce cas révèle
selon vous et est ce que l'association
des maires de france dont vous faites
partie va prendre une position mais je
souhaite ardemment je trouve qu'elle
était un peu silencieuse pour être très
clair dans cette idée que finalement
tout ça reposerait uniquement sur le bon
vouloir des mères je pense que là on a
un vrai sujet et je vais rapidement vous
dire que pour moi c'est peut-être moins
un sujet de laïcité qu'un sujet de
liberté je pense que si on s'appuie
uniquement sur la laïcité pour dire il
ne faut pas qu'ils bossent turquie et
dans les piscines le conseil d'état va
arriver avec ses gros sabots habituel
c'est d'ailleurs ce qui va se passer
vous allez voir la décision va être
porté une batterie ministre hâtif
l'addition de grenoble elle va remonter
au conseil d'état et le conseil d'état
va dire comme il l'a fait en 2016 avec
les arrêtés anti burqini sur les plages
eh bien non les femmes ont le droit
d'avoir un burqini quand elles vont dans
l'eau donc je pense que le sujet c'est
pas le sujet de la laïcité la défense
forme et d'aller citez moi j'en suis un
promoteur vous souvenez mes combats
notamment à chalon dans les cantines et
sur un certain nombre de sujets donc je
ne renie pas du tout ce combat là au
contraire elle est essentielle mais là
on va plus loin ce qui est attaqué c'est
pas la laïcité c'est la liberté des
femmes
c'est à dire que si on reconnaît c'est
pour ça qu'il nous faudrait un vrai
débat politique qu hélas ce président de
la république est sans doute cette
première ministre ne mèneront pas
jusqu'au bout ce débat c'est le suivant
est-ce qu'on peut accepter que la femme
ne soit pas maîtresse de son corps
est-ce qu'on peut accepter qu'au nom
d'une religion qui mène un combat
politique dans ceux qui aujourd'hui en
sont les promoteurs les plus ardents
c'est pas la religion en elle même qui
est en cause ni ceux qui croient bien
entendu ça c'est très respectable c'est
ce qui agite la religion qui l'a
durcissent pour en faire une arme de
conquête politique le burqini est une
arme de conquête politique et donc il
met en cause la libre disposition du
corps par la femme et à partir de là il
est un obstacle à la liberté
républicaine et à l'égalité des sexes
par conséquent donc je pense que le coup
bah politique que nous avons menée il
est sûre ce biais là donc moi je suis
favorable à son interdiction
parce que on peut pas accepter que dans
le pays des droits de l'homme le pays
des lumières le pays de la révolution
française on est aujourd'hui au 21ème
siècle avec des femmes à qui on impose
une tenue parce que des hommes s'en
croient propriétaires ça c'est
intolérable et c'est là dessus que
combat doit être
écoutée on en parlera avec lui je n'en
sais rien je pense que la f1 est un peu
gêné parce qu'encore une fois il ya le
respect de la libre administration des
collectivités territoriales mais il peut
aussi avoir la loi et moi je souhaite
que la loi avance j'ai quelques doutes
encore une fois sur la bonne entente
politique du président de la république
en la matière mais ça c'est un des
combats vous voyez vous puisque vous
demandez pour l'avenir qu'est-ce qui se
passera c'est un des combats je mènerai
et je trouverais notamment dans cette
grande maison du sénat deux des
défenseurs acharnés de la liberté j'ai
cité le sénateur sapin tout à l'heure je
citerai évidemment jacqueline eustache
brinio keita qui mène un combat pour la
liberté contre l'islamisme depuis des
années donc nous sommes un certain
nombre à vouloir aujourd'hui mener ce
combat ensemble merci merci elle était
notre invité ce matin stéphane on
regarde là une mauvaise passe et
elizabeth banks fait son entrée à
matignon c'est à la une de votre journal
merci merci
[Musique]